hello my name is Ahmed Shah be I a
mobile shaver from down man up I'm also
the director director of research and
studies at the Jordan investment port so
I do is trying to attract investment in
my country so good economic development
so I'd like to answer the question about
what is the main reason why Europe is in
a crisis this was asked by Victor 1 2 3
V from YouTube and so when you look at
Europe it's a big continent lots of
countries very diverse it could be
cultural diversity could be economic
Pollock economic policy diversity and
what I feel has happened is that the
card was booked for the horse a mode was
created and hastily adopted and you know
when times were good nobody felt
anything but when things got bad all of
the you know issues came up and people
realized that it doesn't actually fit
all of them so some specific issues
about single currency it prevents other
countries from being competitive from
evaluating from supporting let's say
inter-regional trade what could have
been done is a slow easing process or
countries reform based on clear metrics
and once you reach a certain level then
you can move forward and you know engage
in a whole European Union but I feel for
it to remain successful it needs to be
flexible and accommodating for change
and try and keep in mind the local
context under which each country
operates thanks